all right because i actually have a
serious story i'd like to tell you guys
okay
if there's any scammers there's any
hustlers that are listening right now
and you're trying to make some money
doing illegal [ __ ] i just want to say
in the beginning i don't condone any of
this but this is wrong you shouldn't do
this you shouldn't break the law
in no way are we supporting the breaking
of the law
on this podcast that being said being
said if somebody was to break the law
here is a great way to do it where you
can make a lot of money fast
okay please don't harm anybody okay
there's this this
blogger girl that my my jew wife ought
to be
my jew fiancee his jew beyonce yeah
this jew brought that i live with and
it's gonna be my wife that i'm gonna
make little jewelets
little jew
[Laughter]
you know what's crazy my kids are going
to be jewish and yours aren't
crazy raise them acidic just to rub it
in his face
oh yeah dude i'm going modern earth hey
that's why he wants everybody to post a
blue square so he can see which
christian girls he could [ __ ]
oh my god so you weed out the blues
yeah yeah yeah yeah what a [ __ ]
sellout anyway
so anyway scammers listen up hustlers
listen up okay
so don't do this i'm saying don't do
this my girl follows his blogger
or vlogger right and she's a fashion
vlogger right and her name is uh tamara
kalinich is her name right i think she
lives in paris whatever
and uh she talks about you know getting
bags and how to get bags from these
fancy places
etc the bags are very hard to get it's
kind of like sneakers with us
you know like a drop is hard to get hold
of you have to pay crazy resale you know
there's no flight club for bags but
there are these resale places right
so turns out all these fashion vloggers
right they film all the [ __ ] in their
house
they don't make that much money right
they're not broke but they're not
swimming in it we're not talking about
like millionaires etc but
what they are is selling a lifestyle a
lot of times they get offered like free
trips to certain places to promote a
hotel
to promote uh even like a new restaurant
these types of things
uh these expensive brands will give them
bags they don't have the money to pay
for the bags but you get a free bag from
prada a free bag from hermes maybe not
free bag from mermaids but like
bags from these like super high twos so
they're doing these videos they're doing
in their apartments
they're in like the windows of their
apartments they're maybe on their
balconies you know where these girls
live it's not that hard you can see the
building that's across the street like
it's very easy
they're saying what city they're in this
girl got robbed for 300 000
worth of [ __ ] okay they just came into
her [ __ ] window from the courtyard in
her building
while she was gone she was gone they
knew that she was gone because i think
it was like paris fashion week
so they knew that she was that stupid
she's vlogging and staying where she is
exactly now she said she's careful about
it like i never say where i am like i
will tag a place
but after i've left the place but the
thing that's really interesting about
this
is this is the easiest come up because
the stuff that these girls have
is the most flippable [ __ ] on the street
yes if you get a necklace
for a hundred thousand dollars who are
you selling that necklace to like you
gotta find a jeweler the jeweler's gonna
go i know you stole his [ __ ]
necklace i'm gonna give you 10 percent
of value
a bag right to ebay make even more money
on
docx whatever the [ __ ] done the watches
all this is she had
i think uh what was it 300 000 300 euros
worth of [ __ ] that was missing three
patek philippe
that's half a million dollars half a
million but tech philippe watches get
the [ __ ] out it's the most expensive
watch in the world crazy right
you got a bunch of these bags she had uh
like a whole bunch of [ __ ] that was
taken this is the beginning of this
and the reason this is the beginning is
because usually the people that can
afford this type of stuff right
they got security around them if you got
three patek phillips right yeah you got
security around you
you're moving in a different way you're
in some super expensive building
the thing with this happening right now
is these fashion vloggers
are getting all this expensive [ __ ] that
they could never afford
so now they don't have the lifestyle to
protect it if you got half a million
dollars worth of [ __ ] in your house just
chilling that can be easily removed and
nobody even knows the difference you
just gotta come in with a backpack
yeah right and you have no security
you're not paying for like 24 hours
you can't secure because they can't this
is these are the marks
these are the perfect setups this is not
kim kardashian getting robbed in a hotel
this is the average girl that might be
making under six figures right
so she can't afford the protection for
all the [ __ ] she got in there and
she's displaying all the [ __ ] she got
constantly she's on instagram bragging
yo here's my new hermes
and the scammer's just going oh word
right you don't even have to case it
because like she's showing like here's
my room here's the door
here's where the bathroom is like she's
showing you everything
son i think this is the beginning and i
think all these people are getting how
did it take so long
that's a great question i mean like it's
a great question
we were raised different generation no
internet exposing your whole life no
social media
we're raised don't let don't flaunt your
your [ __ ]
because you'll get robbed their whole
life is flaunting their [ __ ]
how are they not getting robbed i don't
understand how it's not happening
all the time already especially when
when they're not at a a level where they
can protect the [ __ ] they're flaunting
yeah
because usually if you're paying for
something right
you understand that you have to maintain
a lifestyle
that can protect that yeah right like if
you buy a fancy car
you have to have enough money for a
garage yep
right just kind of like basic knowledge
of stuff right
or if you i'm trying to think of another
thing like you get a tesla model from a
guy who can't afford one you put it in
bro bro
[Music]
anyway well this story was happening in
2013 they made that movie bling ring
when when
the first time you really heard about
this was from like when paris hilton and
lindsay lohan because they were
in this jet set crowd that that's when
like the people breaking in it was the
first time you heard that it wasn't like
ski mask like just adult men breaking in
it was like
people that were at the same clubs girls
the groups were girls that would party
with them and they would do that i have
a take on that
i think all that [ __ ] was fake that's
possible well i think all that
insurance fraud insurance fraud so your
point if this girl
that that what's happening now if you're
getting a bag for free
but then you're insuring that bag and
you can get money back
so that's another thing right you could
easily
she can't sell the [ __ ] she gets because
then she's going to ruin the
relationship she has with these brands
yeah
right so how do you make money off of
things you have
yeah right without selling them
you got robbed you can only do this one
time
it's but it's like maybe she's that dumb
but to me
the whole reason you do this is to try
to become a seven figure person for what
you try to ascend to the next level
you can't ever do this again and you are
that person and like how much can you
make selling
though but here's the thing you you
might you don't
have to do it again maybe now she's the
most talked about
right in that circle oh my god you got
robbed it's like
being arrested for a dude is cool
being robbed for a girl is cool like you
have so much cool [ __ ] that
[ __ ] try to rob you
maybe the company it's a true crime
podcast maybe the company doesn't even
care because just saying patek philippe
here
six hundred thousand people who are
protected the companies are through the
roof
our goods are robbable yeah right yeah
like our goods are worth breaking
and now not only is it seen on her
little vlog now
podcasts our podcast podcasts like us
news outlets
they're all mentioning these brands and
it's just word of mouth advertising
and the brands have sympathy for and
they'll be like oh let's give you the
newest one of these
and the newest and then they look good
pr and that's another advertising factor
and she got her insurance money so now
she just got the bill back
that's smart if she did that if that
happened but it's kind of wild though
right like
don't you see these girls as potentially
the new marks oh yeah
dude yeah how's it not happening you
just gotta know how to like
seek him out though because like this
girl's audience i'm sure is all young
female like fashion girls like the only
reason i know this exists is because of
my girl
right works in fashion whereas like this
happens with rappers all the time where
like
they're posting about it but like
they're appealing to an audience of
people that might be more inclined to
steal [ __ ]
right whereas want more because they
have like a bunch of money around their
neck right right
that's way easier to just steal that one
thing than to try to go to
somebody's house yeah they're all like
30 and like always though not always but
if you you know if you're going to rob a
rapper that talks about how he kills
people you got to be prepared yeah even
if you think he's full of it
he might not be true i don't think i
could show up with a gun to this girl's
house yeah if you literally just get in
the front door and you say give me
everything what they gonna do
yeah literally what are they going to do
stop vlogging
but like in the hood for example a lot
of drug dealers get robbed all the time
because they're doing something illegal
so it's like they can't go to the cops
so i think
rappers also kind of you know some of
them are on the line with things so it's
like they
tend to be like oh i'll deal with it in
the streets but just raw
animal fear like that start here you
can't see yes because you talk so much
[ __ ] about how snitching
yeah but then it's more risk to go rob
these types of people because it's like
oh hey if i get you on camera i'm going
to the cops
i'm saying just raw i hear it just raw
fear animal fear
if i rob these rappers it's a thing in
that moment it's a [ __ ] thing
that's i think a more primal fear than
oh they won't be afraid to go to the
cops blah blah blah i just gotta be a
little smarter about that but i'm not
getting into a [ __ ] potential
shootout
if i rob some female vlogger true you
know what i mean but it's
and now with the mask sorry to cut you
but like oh yeah
you just hop in the back of a cab pay
cash
you got a mask on the whole time not an
uber just a cab
color contacts glasses you're good
still difficult bro
you